been rubbing it in your face that this
is my segment kendall all right this is
my segment it is big game sunday coming
up and it's all about football and food
of course carmine's and virgil's has you
covered whether you're in the mood for
italian or southern whatever you want
they have chef executive chef michael
you are here to tell us what's on the
menu yeah so both restaurants at
virgil's uh we're doing a super bowl
party okay game party um you're gonna
also do catering so you got a little bit
of brisket ribs pulled pork we bought a
little battle of the chicken wings for
the for you to decide later virgil's
wings or carmine's wings are better okay
what would you say can you even say that
are you allowed to say which one's
better
no rahman will say
virgils and chef mate would say
carmine's okay so as you continue to
break down what's at virgil's i'm going
to go ahead and do this taste test
myself go for it okay go ahead so yeah
so virgos and we got a little dessert we
brought banana pudding for the rest of
urges to top it off at carmine's i'm
looking in the forum shops we're going
to have a large buffet we can fit up 800
people we have a carving station of new
york strip shellfish display for the vip
package or you get some baked ziti
chicken parm penny alla vodka uh classic
sausage and peppers vegetarian option we
have a little eggplant parm some caesar
salad and to top it off for everybody
your favorite tiramisu tiramisu i'm go
ahead and just pick that up and eat it
right just like it is
chef's
chef's favorite porterhouse
okay
now you were telling us the most
difficult thing
here to make is the barbecue because
it's you know it takes a lot of love and
patience right yeah i mean that virgil's
we scratch kitchen all the barbecue
meats are marinated for 24 hours slow
cooked anywhere from 12 to 14 hours
the wings are slow cooked for four hours
i mean oh my gosh cheese fries or train
wreck fry start off an appetizer before
you dig into the barbecue some great
options
and then after super bowl we got a
little bit of uh valentine's stuff oh
following
i thought we were just talking about the
big game but we got valentine's day too
tell us tell us more yeah so at virgos
we're doing a 32 ounce porterhouse for
two with some shrimp skewers a choice of
two sides okay for 99. and carmine's
just doing the spaghetti carbonara
we're doing a roasted beef tenderloin
two and a half pounds and also a seafood
stuffed salmon
okay so romantic but also sporty ever
you guys have everything at carmine's
and virgil's now you guys are doing some
packages right yeah we're doing some to
go packages for catering uh the
restaurant's almost sold out we still do
have some tickets available so you can
call the restaurant okay uh we'll still
get you in some bar seats of virgil some
vip package or the regular tailgate
package at carmine's i love it and
there's something called the hero
platter yeah so it caramelizes what is
that caramel is a hero platter okay so a
couple your choice of grilled vegetables
chicken parm meatball parm
anywhere from 12 to 15 heroes we cut
them up it feeds 15 20 people dang okay
i love it here i love it here okay
kendall you okay over there i know
you're jealous i know you i know it okay
i think we have an answer
virgil's wing carmine's wing
i got to go with carmine's car minecraft
i got to go to carmine's what what is
that glaze on it because that's what's
really setting it off a whole lot of
butter white wine lemon juice fresh
butter yeah the wings are marinated also
24 hours then we toss it nice herb lemon
sauce
well thank you
the entire station will be eating this
today so thank you for stopping by we
definitely brought enough for everybody
for sure all right carmine's virgil's
one-stop shop for football and
valentine's day
all right kendall awesome to see you
absolutely sorry not sorry all right